how do you feel about flat earth
i mean it's flat
you're right you're running with flatter
theory yeah my uncle one time so i'm
from maine i'm a lobster fisherman right
so my my uncle one time
he got in his boat
and he went way past the
three-mile line
all the way out towards canada and i
swear to god we never saw that
again he went all the way
past towards canada and i believe
personally that he sailed off the edge
of the earth well there's always the
marianas trench and you know that it
splits the earth in clean in half right
and so if you if you fall off the edge
of the earth you just go straight in yep
yep all right i feel like you can define
up
um are those people serious like that
has to be a joke right like if they're
joking that's really funny if they're
not joking it's even funnier but sad
because presumably folks like that vote